if you look everywhere around you it's
kind of like what James Brown said was
that every piece of music after him you
could hear a little bit of James Brown
that's like black history in a nutshell
I think black history is so important
because it's kind of like your time to
be celebrated there should be a month
where we celebrate amazing leaders that
fought for freedom for everybody it
gives a more complete picture of the
history of the United States
Black History Month means people can
overcome a lot of sad oppressive things
and come out being big and beautiful and
shine right through it's the story about
civil disobedience it's about people
grabbing power the first book I ever
read where I was like I relate to this
so much was black boy by Richard Wright
it was about like poverty and struggle
and trying to overcome obstacles and
that was the first time I was like wow
learning about hip-hop when I was young
graffiti I'm seeing deejaying
breaking without that I wouldn't be who
I was today black folk in America came
over and chips look at the way that you
came in but you look at yourself now and
you're like whoa we are [ __ ] blowing
up do I listen to those stories and
identify with them regardless of what
color I am yeah
and I think it's important for everyone
to hear this I think of black leaders
such as Angela Davis I admire them I
read all their books and life you know
it's like we're crossing rivers and
we're crossing borders and we're in the
back of cars sometimes to get here and
it's almost like well I look at them
like we can do it too just close your
eyes and listen to the stories and you
will relate because they're American
stories